ساعات قبل حلول ظلام الساب من اكتوبر ودون
الاعلان عن ساعه الصفر بدات اسرائيل
التوغل في قطاع
غزه الهدف الاول بحسب رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي هو القضاء على حركه حماس
استبقت ذلك بتنفيذ مشغلات محدوده في مناطق
عده من حدود القطاع توغلات بطيئه باليات
ثقيله واقل عدد ممكن من الجنود ونافذه
زمنيه ضيقه حاولت من خلالها استطلاع ملامح
البيئه التي ستقاتل فيها والاهم اختبار
مستويات الاستعداد لدى فصائل المقاومه في
وقت كانت القوات الاكبر عددا والاعلى
تجهيزا تتحضر عند تخوم
القطاع مناوره تقليديه في الحروب المعاصره
وكذا الحال نفسه في تكتيك المعركه تمهيد
ناري قصف عنيف ومستمر للترويح ومحاوله
الوصول للانفاق بالقصف العميق بذخائر
مضاده للتحصينات فما بين السابع من اكتوبر
والعمليه البريه نفذت ما يقرب من 500 ساعه
من القصف والقت قرابه 20 ال طن من المتفجر
في ذلك اليوم دفعت بوحدات من ثلاثه
محاور من الشمال عبر بيت حانون والشمال
الغربي قرب بيت لاهيه لتغطيه المساحه
الممتده من البحر المتوسط غربا حتى السياج
الحدودي
شرقا ومن الوسط اجتازت الاراضي الزراعيه
من جحر الديك وصولا لشارع صلاح الدين
والهدف تقطيع اوصال لشمال بخطوط عرضيه
وطوليه مع الابقاء على الغطاء الناري بقصف
مدفعي وجوي وبحري كانت مهمه كتائب القسام
وفصائل المقاومه اكثر صعوبه من الناحيه
النظريه بغياب التكافؤ في ميزان القوه من
حيث التجهيز والتسليح واعداد الجنود لكن
المقاومه اظهرت جانبا من الوجه الذي كثيرا
ما بقي
غامضا وحدات قتاليه مختلفه المهام الويه
متعدده نظام بقي فعالا للتواصل والتنسيق
واعطاء
الاوامر ولعبت قدره المقاومه على سرعه
استقراء خطط القوات المتوغلة
ئه مسرح القتال لا تزيد مساحه القطاع على
365 كيلومترا وهو واحد من اكثر الاماكن
اكتظاظا بشريا
وعمرانيا محاصر منذ سنوات وسكانه يعرفونه
عن ظهر قلب والمقاومون يعرفون ارضه وما
تحتها اصطدمت قوات الاحتلال بعقد قتاليه
قاسيه وحي الشجاعيه داها حاصره لواء نخبه
المشاه جولاني وسجل فيه الخسائر التي تعد
الاكبر في تاريخه اي
اضرب مخيم البريج وخان يونس ايضا واجهت
اسرائيل فيهما مشاكل على صعيد الانجاز
الميداني والخسائر
البشريه مع بدايه الشهر الثاني للحرب
البريه توسعت العمليه العسكريه بمهاجمه
جنوب القطاع ولاحقا الوسط بشكل شبه
متزامن دفعت اسرائيل الالويه التي ستقاتل
في جنوب القطاع عبر شارع صلاح الدين دون
ان تتمكن من الاطباق على مدينه خان يونس
الجراره توقفت عندها القوه المهاجمه دون
ان تحرز
تقدما وتعرضت لهجمات اوقعت خسائر في
الجنود والاليات عند هذه النقطه وبعد
قرابه شهرين على العمليه اعادت اسرائيل
توزيع جيشها سحبت الويه ابرزها جولاني
ودفعت بثمانيه الويه الى الجنوب بينما
قدرت واشنطن عدد الجنود في الشمال بنحو 50
الفا بحسب نيويورك تايمز وبالتوازي كثفت
كتائب القسام من
هجماتها وما تظهره صور الكتائب هو اعتماد
الكمائن وحقول الغام وعمليات استدراج
مركبه وعدلت من تكتيكها القتالي مؤكده
سلامه واستمراريه تسلسل اصدار وتنفيذ
الاوامر
الميدانيه وعلى بعد اكثر من 100 يوم على
بدء المعركه من العسير رؤيه طريق واضح
لنصر عسكري حاسم لاسرائيل تقول صحيفتها
ارتس فالمعطيات
تجعل الحسم الاسرائيلي امرا بعيد المنال
ولم تعد اولويه على الاقل في تصريحات بني
جانس نسيها او ادرك صعوبه
تحقيقها